so I want to bring up second channels
Iraq has now this little Vlog channel uh
Ryan Trahan uh Creator support Connor
Samir they're starting a new channel
so what do you guys think about second
channels I think I think starting a
second channel is it made it depends on
the season but it's underrated because
you can just have the systems in place
to be able to have something on a
separate Channel it allows you to a lot
of times be a little bit more creative
because you're not you don't feel so
boxed in but I think more people can
actually do it if they just have the
right systems my take is that second
channels are
overrated for small and new creators too
many people that are just starting are
thinking about starting two or three
channels and I think that's the wrong
move you should start with a focus the
creators you mentioned are established
they have momentum they've got resources
they've got money
and 100 agree with Omar as well that it
could be a part and should be a part of
your YouTube Journey
but should probably be avoided on your
YouTube day one what about as I would
ask you what about think media what in
you felt like I need it's time to start
a second channel do a podcast
I think that starting a second channel
for the think media podcast versus think
media
part of it was the Simplicity of the
audience because a lot of times I think
people subscribe to think media because
of camera reviews and video editing
tutorials and the strategy
business-minded Creator marketing tips
build a business is different than that
and there was enough difference and then
following that line of thinking starting
from scratch devoted calling putting
podcast in the actual title there was
then layered reasoning I do think that
if the audience was the exact same that
it would have been possible to
potentially keep it on the same channel